[Music]
hi greg is my name hi I'm John Oh strums
first 100 days in office blue 28
Helly pull request we check it out but
before we do that we recently launched
the patreon so many of your wonderful
beautiful human beings have gone over
there join the community and meet some
awesome contributions all going through
the channel so thank you guys so much
and we just want to give a couple of
mentions of some exciting things we got
going on over there right now all right
so let's face it most folks they come to
this channel because they want to see
what the reactions the movie reviews are
is and their sketches whenever they come
out everything else only like the really
dedicated people who just like a budget
is like doesn't matter the content will
go over a watch it's what we figured we
would do is we would take all that all
the smaller shows all the stuff that's a
little more crafted a little more
creative and stuff that's a little more
passion project II and move it over to
patreon so that the people who are
really into it can go directly there for
it we can focus the channel more on what
people want it for so we figured we
would move the movie news over there
we're going to move great John's fan
fiction aka how it could work
yeah over there we've got a couple other
ideas that we're thinking about we're
going to put up some behind the scenes
footage we haven't put enough
behind-the-scenes footage actually happy
for really liking that cut out bits and
you know deleted seen some stuff for
extended moments so we got a lot of fun
content we think that you guys would
probably yeah enjoy if you enjoy this
channel and also you know would like the
restrictor mode on YouTube a lot we we
watch a little more of what we actually
say yeah over there on patreon yeah we
don't know we'd have to worry about
saying words like [ __ ] the little
insensitive
yeah we're always thinking of
interesting ways of expanding and trying
out new things and our patreon community
seems like a great place to start and we
notice that most people who decide to be
a part of our patreon are the people
that like watch the movie yeah and we
have like the movie news of the week
segment that we were
that we were thinking of still trying
out here that's like a five-minute video
our movie news over there is like a full
like 45 minutes to an hour length yeah
it's kinda like a video Punk yeah so
this channel is going to be just
primarily directed at the stuff that you
guys mainly watch from now on you know
the reactions are reviews and more
sketches I am NOT replacing ham don't
wrinkle the suit hundred days in all
this so many accomplishments low in my
gold handicap my photo Paula we
increased by 700 and finally we could
share alternating bears my boys all of
them sir here's Anna feel that you must
read immediately it lowers taxes for
only Republicans ok bucks news read it
now watch what they say no you have to
read it I'm Supreme Court just this year
thanks Ruth Bader Ginsburg seat on the
bench you can buy about his robe with
gavel earrings for only 1000 rubles just
read you replace me with Garland in a
whole four years all right
please yes the President of the United
States of time
he's only 70 years old huh taking me
back to where I came from we are 6.8
percent of the brain home paid for by
anybody else 2020 fun thing Fox take a
stab at Fox yeah I wonder how that works
out I'm behind me exactly they're not
always nice when the citizens as one of
these I feel like that's one of the one
of the places that they still grab
everyone's attentions when they do like
a really cool intro bit this felt a
little unfinished no I mean like part of
an episode or like an excerpt yeah I was
told that it was a like a short film The
Simpsons release oh okay because I
consider
not sound it now yeah I thought it was
like some special promo busy shock
theater season 28 those guys are still
fun did he I'll be on like I watch The
Simpsons maybe like the first 10 years
but after that I it's been a while good
18 years
is it a bit a long time since I like
thoroughly follow that show yeah cuz
they're in season 28 and there's like
what twenty-something episodes of season
I keep wanting to check back in because
it's been a while so I watched a new
episode you'll want to see what the tone
is like now oh I remember when I last
checked in like they're trying to keep
it more with the speed of shows that
they have like Family Guy on American
Dad a lot of kind of ways I'm going to
fake cutaways I would just say it moves
a lot quicker and a lot more zany but
there were more cutaway because I caught
some some reason episodes and there are
more like let's put something whacky in
here that's random I heard a fan theory
and one of the early episodes of The
Simpsons homeboy goes into a coma
it was after that episode when
everything becomes like a lot more
ridiculous and Homer Akira coverage
everyone recovers from every injury
no one ever ages so there's a fan theory
that this is all part of homers coma
because that's when the show got really
zany and ridiculous whoa
after that coma episode that crazy what
point in a series of that I think it was
like the first season Jenny yeah first
or second season and I was like hey does
man theory doesn't make it entirely you
know not believable I could see that
somehow being possible video episodes
like when they go to the future they're
grown-up but you're like you never seen
him grow up here yeah yeah they're
always in the same clothes and stuff
yeah what is frozen entire deck is
they're just frozen in Homer coma ah
Homer skelemans a good name for Homer's
coma
yeah that's beer a bad name we are
homers then we have a really lengthy
explanation as to you know it's just
this fancy really foot set for you guys
some sex was bring there hey Donald
Trump's first 100 days in office yeah it
happened we survived he made so many
promises Oh during his campaign what he
would do in his first 100 days in office
I'm here to tell you guys everything
you've heard on the news and
wrong yep he has done everything they
done said he would do it's been huge
huge have anything is his he is tweeted
I can I can name you guys all the things
he's done differently in the first 100
years all the change a lot differently
all the changes he said he was going to
make during his campaign all things he
said he was going to make better or
whatever you think is better or worse he
said he would do in the first 100 days
whatever you can remember just know he
did it uh yeah I would give you examples
but I want you to feel smart enough to
go and just learn it on your own because
if I just say it you won't remember it
so I'm protecting you I'm protecting you
but not yeah oh dude yeah I mean you can
you know he's done I mean we don't have
to say what he's done cuz he's done at
all you did yeah yeah this is the kind
of Republican I would be I wouldn't be
the angry in-your-face kind of
Republican with no real logical facts
against either that cliche well not all
Republicans are like that I know that
but I would be the one who's just like I
know you're you're wrong I just don't
want to say why I just I disagree with
you I want you to know I just want I
disagree that's that's fake news let's
leave it at that
not a fan of confrontation I like to
push my beliefs on anybody I just
thought you should know that will trump
something no he hasn't
let's just leave it we don't have to say
anymore I think that that's what you
think
oddly enough I mean that leaves reduce a
lot of like you know vitriolic conflicts
you know even though I didn't agree with
everything he said he would do in his
first 100 days I think it shows true
character that he at least did every
thing he said he would do in those first
100 days what you know those things that
he's done yeah yeah look if you make a
list hang up on Australia if there's one
thing I've done from all these talk show
hosts and news reports and articles is
that if you make a list of all the
things Trump's that he do in his first
100 days compared to the things he
actually did do you know like he I'm
trying to say he's done them all when
he's done so much and so little all of
the things I mean he's done things we
didn't think you would do yeah just to
add on to the fact that he did all the
things he said you were too strong is
like a guy who already understood that
he's not going to attempt to do the
homework
however yeah he did do the extra credit
assignment hooray for Trump yeah
congratulations for were here after a
hundred days and thanks for three years
this year's awesome yeah Trump is
president YouTube's going through and ad
pocalypse Ben Affleck snot directing the
Batman everything is in perfect
alignment man things are going real real
well and and then we have the Simpsons
and Donald Trump is ready for that
surprises no one on YouTube is blaming
Trump for our problems Trump doesn't
watch a show you a cutie really Ellen
you do it not and I YouTube he goes the
Twitter and Fox team yeah hey hey season
28 of Simpsons keep a lookout subscriber
the real real 5 of the president yeah
that's crazy best season 45 it's gonna
be in my lab or in my last 8 years it is
my last eight years or my last like 9
months I don't know what should dude if
we couldn't get Trump out of office out
of cooks out of so many things he's done
including the whole tak [ __ ] there's no
way he's leaving
he can't do anything wrong I yeah I
don't ready to get enlisted people Oh
who I don't even you know any background
information on who the enemy is
if Trump's gonna start a war
where's that draft you hear that this is
forever account is going up ad blowing
yeah it has a flood I'm doing one yeah
I'm like this this is how we make the
channel better a girl in a crisis
situation subscribe is a real rejects
woo these reasons to Jerry on their
internet Instagram he manages media of
people's social life on the real rejects
and Blum house hey we already mentioned
the patriotic it happen